we finally have a scoring of the new
version of the Republican American
Health Care Act from the Congressional
Budget Office and it is every bit as bad
as the worst prediction that any of us
were making the Congressional Budget
Office found that this new and improved
iteration of the American Health Care
Act which was voted in favor of by
Republicans in the House not yet voted
on in the Senate not only would it raise
the deficit but millions of people would
lose their health insurance and people
would have to pay higher premiums for
the health insurance that they do have
Republicans now are really in a tough
spot because the CBO report for this new
iteration is out as of yesterday 14
million people will likely lose their
health coverage by 2020 23 million
people will likely lose their health
care coverage by 2026 compared to
leaving the Affordable Care Act in place
the CBO determined that if you have
pre-existing conditions there are many
people who will lose coverage which is
obvious given what we already knew about
the bill because this bill will allow
States to seek waivers which would let
insurance companies jack up the prices
drastically for people with pre-existing
conditions what's the point of saying
hey we're going to protect people with
pre-existing conditions except if States
want to waive out of that it's sort of
like not having it in the first place
here is a quote from the CBO's analysis
premiums would vary significantly
according to health status and the types
of benefits provided and less healthy
people would face extremely high
premiums over time it would become more
difficult for less healthy people
including people with pre-existing
medical conditions in those states to
purchase insurance because their
premiums would continue to increase
rapidly also from the CBO report quote
people who are less healthy including
those with pre-existing or newly
acquired medical conditions would
ultimately be unable to publish to
purchase comprehensive non-group health
insurance at premiums contract
comparable to those under current law if
they could purchase it at all many
Republicans are saying but hey that's
only if States choose to use those
waivers we don't know
that they'll take the waivers well the
CBO weighed in on that as well saying
yeah the states are by and large going
to take those waivers quote about
one-sixth of the population resides in
states that would obtain waivers
premiums would vary significantly
according to health status and the types
of benefits provided and less healthy
people would face extremely high
premiums the CBO also said that the
markets in states that take waivers will
become quote unstable and ironically and
maybe ironically isn't even the right
word tragically we know that those are
more likely to be states that have
Republican governors and/or Republican
legislatures in states that take waivers
people will pay more for the essential
health benefits like maternity care
mental health substance abuse emergency
services prescription drugs
hospitalization this is every bit as bad
and worse pat than what we what we
feared and of course the original
version of the american health care act
was also scored by the CBO in March yeah
and that report found that twenty four
million people would lose their coverage
so I guess this is a step in the right
direction but it's obviously not going
to be a big panacea you make it harder
for some people to be able to enforce
insurance you can tell why if some
Republicans were just trying to push
this through before the CBO could score
it so two things one we now know why
Republicans voted on it so quickly
before the CBO could score because the
CBO numbers are disastrous but you
actually have Republicans who have the
audacity to come out and say hey this is
a good report it's better than the first
one it's a better report we had 24
million people who are going to lose
coverage in the in a decade with the
first one now only 23 million people are
going to lose what level of depravity do
you need to be afflicted by in order to
say this is a victory because 23 million
rather than 24 million people are going
to lose health care coverage it's
immoral
yeah I think we need 23 more amendments
or new version of the vice bill before
we start heading into the right
direction yeah if each amendment gets
you a million fewer people losing
coverage we're only twenty three
amendments away from getting something
that's not going to be a disaster I like
that yeah but Republicans are owning up
to this they say it's not about insuring
the most amount of people possible about
lowering the premiums for people who are
younger and healthy and the big picture
remains the same which is you can't
revamp the Affordable Health Care
act without making it more liberal than
Obamacare and still increase coverage
and access while decreasing cost it just
can't be done period we've talked about
that and obviously no bill is going to
fulfill Donald Trump's promise to create
health care that covers more people as
well as with lower out-of-pocket
expenses and lower premiums it just
can't happen but Republicans are
ideologically committed to this idea of
repeal the Affordable Care Act and by
golly that's what they're going to do no
matter whether it kills them or more
likely whether it kills people that can
no longer afford insurance